mais un coup de griffe qui passe tout
alors oui j'ai un coup de riffs alors la
transition et j'ai un coup de griffe
parce que en fait ils ont décalé des
matches de football le vendredi 24
juillet et le 5 vendredi 31 juillet ils
vont jouer la finale de la coupe de
france et la finale de la coupe de la
ligue psg saint-etienne et psg lyon or
les finales de coupe de france c'est
bien de les jouer dès samedi
parce que c'est assez agréable pour les
gens c'est toujours gardé l'argent qui
travaillent a toujours qui fait toujours
qui fait donc là ils ont décidé de
décaler les matchs au vendredi pour une
simple et bonne raison
laisser la place à fort boyard qui est
diffusée le samedi sur ce alors
maintenant on marche sur la tête on a un
pays champion du monde on a un pays cap
cacapa joue au football depuis quatre
mois pour des bonnes raisons
on a arrêté trop tôt championnat selon
moi et la maintenance et le père fouras
décide un lieu décalé les matchs du
vendredi sexy que non mais non mais tu
rigole mais je jure à l'arrivée l'âge et
j'adore la grippe a je rigole pas
j'adore fort boyard
moi je dis qu'on rigole pas tous les
deux j'adore fort boyard j'adore
l'émission j'adore maximy l'été c'est
super mais faut penser aux gens aux
supporters de football qui ont pris leur
place pour la coupe de france et la
coupe de la ligue la porte ses bras le
vendredi quand tu habites à
saint-etienne que tu vas devoir aller à
vendredi monter sur paris après le
boulot c'est quoi ce délire c'est
n'importe quoi c'est quoi ça on est où
là où je suis d'accord avec lui
n'importe quoi s'y perdre alors le père
fouras et qui sait le nouvel anne
hidalgo ma réussite de tous
non mais c'est qui ce mec l'année le
voilà oui je vous adore et jeannot
raymond mais je suis pas du tout
d'accord d'avoir quoi mais parce qu'on
fait ça n'a aucun intérêt ce que tu nies
raimon du mois
alors là les émissions à 4 heures du
matin j'étais brain et du k2 colada dans
les bois selon lui a donné raison mais
je ne sois pas d'accord avec toi parce
que d'abord fondé font une opération
commerciale
ils sont là pour gagner de l'argent à
l'époque a été difficile fort boyard ça
cartonne pendant l'été ils vont devoir
laisser
et puis les matchs de foot on a été
tellement ce vrai que ce soit le
vendredi ou le samedi tradition decideo
l'air d'un gars comme ça tu crois moi
quand je fus rabat la passion à
saint-etienne tue la passion à lyon tu
la connais sera l'année des blessures à
29 ans la reina et ramal où vivent 12
ans non non non non je déconne là et je
t'aime beaucoup géraldine et là tu es en
train de faire une énorme erreur
[Rires]
géraldine oui dix mois ça m'étonne de
toi qui est spécialisé media devrait
encore y tue les français sont là pour
faire de l'argent au contraire c'est une
mission de service public
il ya hilare devant celle ci soit pas
une chaîne commerciale dictée par les
l'audience en foutant fait sentir il
songe alors merci alors tu as perdu ta
voix hier vendredi je suis désolé bien
suisse attention j street là mais quand
tu veux tu la mise surtout dali football
sa création là je suis pas d'accord avec
vous et avec vous êtes en train de faire
une mine d'or moi je suis complètement
d'accord avec géraldine il n'est pas à
sacrifier fort boyard qui quand même un
peu cocorico non mais c'est une énorme
ce qui est dur de moyens a été super en
danger elle ne souhaitait pas parler et
ont besoin ajouté
on a regardé des programmes de merde
pendant tout le conflit ce n'est pas
raison tout sacrifier les programmes ils
les ont rallongé
ils ont supprimé tous les films ils ont
tous affiché un appétit c'est sur ces
huit ans mais n'a pas qu'est ce que tu
es jeune tu amir eshel la compagnie
soeur alors que shell concots est à la
hauteur mais la plupart des gens dont on
a et on en met en danger le bêtisier de
noël on met nos efforts et ça a marché
et bah oui les gens n'y a plus de saison
non mais on touche et la gaillarde les
vendre tu peux des cas les deux
émissions de fort boyard de la jette au
train de faire une mine non non mais
surtout qu'en plus c'est quand même des
événements enfin pour le coup les
finales de coupes nationales c'est quand
même vraiment cédé événement vraiment
nationaux et les attentions jour ça
rassemble des familles qui peuvent comme
tu le disais mon probablement ma place
est avant tout pareil et je dois encore
meilleur et je pense vraiment vraiment
vraiment que ses fins pour le coup c'est
important est qu en effet un fort boyard
qui est décalé un vendredi c'est pas la
fin du monde
on est à l'étranger d'accord j'ai réduit
ma dit en train de faire énorme erreur
de l'averse déstabiliser pour 24 heures
des différences franchement c'est pas
nous lancer
ça veut pas aller faire du covan faire à
part à new delhi avec moi dkw est
ancienne et installa rendez vous samedi
pourquoi effectivement c'est un bon
comédien sacrifiait fin j'ai prolongé
pour une redevance de tf1 fr2 truc quand
il ya des trucs sportif il décale danse
avec les chars par exemple je dis voilà
mais il aurait pu le faire il aurait
néanmoins hier le bruit la coupe de
france c'est le savez c'est pas fini la
ligue
j'espère que la ligue va bouger c'est
faire décoller des colons britanniques
je suis la ligue
j'appelle tf1 moi ce match on attaque on
attaque un des problèmes le plus fort de
tf1 ils sont maryse hilsz a bien sûr
mais une semaine commente à pourvoir
dans notre programme des matchs les six
là où on est où là vous vous êtes au 38
rue des meilleurs énorme carton